hey guys the night pants nation tour
continues october 23rd baltimore
maryland one night only there's already
a low ticket count gonna have to add a
show so get on those tickets now october
28th brea california november 12th and
13th arlington virginia get your tickets
now at
ryansickler.com
i'm comedian ryan sickler and this is my
stepson derek crawford while we were on
quarantine class might have been out but
school was still in session all right
let's go
it's a very serious business you have
lives especially this one
in your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah dude we jumped the [ __ ] out of them
oh
no hold on a minute look at it
look at the aloha
the virus y'all
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane your herky
jerky with turns
you look like patrick mahomes sister
patricia this hair is beautiful you look
like fatty my hopes bro
you've got to run a red light it's going
to be red and there it is
the cops come in they're pepper spraying
everybody come on we can't get arrested
the f building is either used for
fighting if you're blinking
what a different world hey thank you for
taking me out driving man it means a lot
you got lucky bro you could have had a
real piece of [ __ ] instead you got a
pretty decent piece of [ __ ]
go all the way down to lincoln and up
ocean park
watch where you're going you blew right
through a crosswalk
we getting poured over
geez but that was always good
this does not go for my anxiety
this is learner's permit
[Music]
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media make sure you go to my website get
your tickets to the night pants nation
tour
uh make sure you subscribe to the
youtube
and the patreon if you or someone you
know has a story that has to be heard
please submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com
and uh hopefully we get to do an episode
with you it's five bucks a month all
right and you get the honeydew a day
early ad free
and uh
if you sign up for a year you get over a
month free all at no additional cost all
right and the stories right now are just
insane they're not stopping i promise
you got an email list full of stuff
going we're going through right now and
it's such a good show and i can't thank
you enough for your support all right uh
honeydew podcast is the dot com is the
website and uh there it is you know we
do over here we highlight the low lights
uh these are the stories behind the
storytellers i'm very excited to have
this storyteller on here today first
time here on the honeydew some maryland
love ladies and gentlemen hi shafir
welcome to the honeydew thank you very
much you look good dude you reminded me
about marilyn just real quick i was
wearing some maryland shorts you always
do yeah i know no one reps the flag like
our state reps our flag
you know what's funny about that what i
when you live there
you don't think about it i didn't until
i got out and then i stepped away and
someone said
people in maryland rep their flag harder
than people in texas and i was like
they're too we do yeah easily i thought
that is a weird thing that we're so flag
proud but we do have a kick ass flap but
also we go like entire outfits yeah full
i realized it's a firefly like five six
years ago and it was in delaware and
then all you could the maryland full
it's not
cities logos everything yeah crab a
bumper sticker shaped like a crab i got
that magnet on my fridge yeah and on a
pint glass yeah they've made one of
those with like a darwin mashup right
probably with like no legs or something
yeah yeah
um
yeah we rap it [ __ ] hard hard
anyway some guy wrote it's like hey if
you're from maryland you can't wear that
[ __ ] like coming at me and i was like
first of all i am and second of all so i
am so i know that's not a rule yeah what
are you talking about
i'm from there yeah anyone's allowed to
wear it
what are you talking it's not a frat bro
no
um well i'm stoked to have you here dude
yeah it's good to be here um it's good
to have you sweetheart studio thank you
man
um please plug everything
all of it right now all right i'm well
i'm gonna take out the gates at the
gates i'm on tour right now be in boston
december 9th
uh cleveland and phoenix and uh and
denver are coming up in february and uh
and vancouver as well
yeah i'm [ __ ] touring and loving it
love and stand up got taken away for too
long now it's back my podcast already
should be a skeptic tank
have you not been on there no remember
we did um we did have to promote my
album and we did a half of one outside
at the store and that's all we could do
i guarantee you i have that we if we
i mean you did you put it up i did put a
heart
yeah and you put it preceding another
episode and it was like a definition a
sort of like a one-two uh episode yeah
yeah we got to finish it off though i
would love to
let's do it we got to like the most
tragic part
and that's a wrap
you had a [ __ ] stupid kid it ruins my
dumb kids yeah that scenario
um
yeah yeah yeah all right we got to
finish that that was great all right you
should first scavenge it's on youtube
and then um
and then i do other stuff on youtube
youtube.com
i have yoga classes on there
we're doing one after this you'll be on
yeah yeah yeah are you gonna teach me
yoga i mean yoga but you're yoga i'm a
yogi yeah all right yeah you're my yoga
yeah
oh so this is real well you said when
you said stupid you just were calling it
stupid no i mean
yeah yeah no it's legitimately yeah okay
you're about to give me some real yoga
no no it will try our best
it's accessible all right have you ever
done it yoga yeah yeah a couple times
perfect i have a mat in my car right now
i could go get i'm where you were if i
did it like 20 more times okay
so like i just like i know those okay
cool i know what to teach you yeah i
know a little bit of [ __ ]
i might be able to show you all the
moves but i'll be like i'll get you to
where your imagination can fill in what
it should look like okay
you'll go with ari
i've seen your videos yeah and you wore
the maryland shorts in it yeah yeah
every day you took them to quarantine
that's where i did the first one
yeah it was great
all right
he said he was like he was like so were
you just teaching like legitimate yoga i
don't understand i'm like he goes oh it
goes then i saw one and one of the moves
you were like
saying that hitler gets the job done or
something like that and then it hit me
like oh you're joking i'm like yeah nate
i mean they're moves but like i'm not
gonna teach it seriously seriously
i apologize for you all of a sudden he's
a [ __ ] real yogi yeah dude we did him
in um in ecuador we found a place with
just a beautiful backdrop and i do there
in the mornings and i shaved my head i
did a whole series all right let's talk
about it okay because your traveling is
has been over the years has been insane
i love that you do this thank you um
especially as a divorcee you are a
divorcee technically do you remember
when i [ __ ] called you that in san
francisco and go oh my god you're a
divorcee you're like i am a divorce wow
yeah it hit me again you're technically
a divorcee i will fill it out every once
in a while and it's there i'm like you
know what yeah i guess so
um
so you can travel you can pick up at
tonight you can be like [ __ ] it i'm
going to ecuador you could and you do
you do things like that so talk to me
about some of this travels you've had
some pretty scary uh stuff sometimes
sometimes that one in ecuador i remember
getting that spot and like and the
people next to us i just went for it to
look like a stupid so
finding how are you finding these spots
airbnb is everywhere plus it's crooked
as [ __ ] in ecuador so if you stay for a
week and you like it you're like can we
just do this oh forget all those fees
and like absolutely catch me so it's
great okay it works out really well
cheap
so we found a great one just an overlook
of like a city and a lake weight so i
just doing yoga and then shave my head
got like a white outfit
from um from this market town and then
the people read into us they left me
like what do you guys teach yoga in
america and i was like no like the
shaved head and i had to look up how to
say bromeyer how to say joke and like
what's the joke i'm like
i'm just bad at this i don't know the
joke is i don't do this and i'm like i
don't get it anyway it's online
yeah but i like going places i went to i
went to china did one that run in china
are you doing stand up on these yeah you
are yeah it's not just traveling this
last one ecuador was just traveling okay
uh southeast asia was just travel i
finished a special and i was like
i already had in my head like i'll edit
that thing and then i have no
responsibility let me get lost
and where's the where is the scariest
place you've been
it's always the first places you step
off the plane another place all the all
the [ __ ] the the fear of other [ __ ]
kicks in and you're just like they must
be trying to rob me myanmar was like
it's the most buddhist friendly country
and you're me like [ __ ] it everybody's
gonna rob me like always worried and
this is not real at all like at all um
one guy was like we were trying to like
hike to a [ __ ] long long
like we got the bus station everybody's
right there we're like come our cabs our
cabs it's just overwhelming i don't know
i'm an introvert that shit's like no no
no i'll [ __ ] myself over and just walk
away and then like think about it but
then i'm like i for sure should have
gotten a cab would have been like three
dollars when maybe it should have been
two like i'm not you know what i mean
yeah my line adjusts to what i'm
supposed to spend as like a backpacker
um
but then i'm just like walking some guy
pulls up and he's like a little bit of
english and he was like where are you
going and we're like to this thing it's
like i can i can uh take you if you want
or like i can give you directions
and um and we're like no what
like what do you want what's like your
goal and he's like all right you got i
am trying to practice my english
and you're like all right
it was just really nice and they drove
us one by one like two miles down the
road and come back it was crazy one by
one yeah we all just went why one by one
motorcycles oh he's gone
yeah
yeah so this group he started going like
we were in like um somewhere in the
south and then
me and mars like um
they just got freedom back from the
military military took over put their
leader under house arrest and just like
couldn't do [ __ ] there and they just
opened up to tourism like 15 20 years
ago something like that so it's all uh
real new yeah but there's areas where
they're still they haven't
gotten done like um you know
ethnically cleansing so they're still
taking care of it so they don't let
foreigners into those areas no yeah
they're real oh yeah
yeah they're like
they're like slowly like taking those
we're killing these people you're pretty
much out in there pretty much they'll
say like no it's not whatever but like
they're not they're not that's like the
parents bedroom like you can go wherever
you want the house just don't go in yeah
they won't let foreigners in there they
won't like foreigners
motorized vehicles at all so they work
around it and like by gone in like
really nice places like really old
places they'll like get you like
electric scooters
so you could like see stuff because it's
not like
with the motor but anyway there's whole
swaths where you can't go into so
where's it like that so like if this is
myanmar you can go here and then you can
go here and then none of this top part
and none of this side
shaw state sean state something like
that but anyway we had a bus from here
this awesome lake here where the bus
goes we just saw the route it goes like
this and we didn't know we're like why
it's like we did the gps yeah the google
maps we can get there in 13 hours
and this was like a day and a half
so the three of us were just like let's
just go for it so we didn't read the
rules but foreigners aren't allowed to
like sleep there you can just drive
through
so we get out the first day somewhere in
the middle and then we go to hotel and
they all just stare at us what do you
mean like we get there how many people
three guys playing poker over there
um
and then nobody behind the counter right
here so we go in and we look at them and
they're looking at us they'll say a word
don't say a word they're just staring
see that that [ __ ] creeps me out it
wasn't dangerous like stare like like
i was just like what the [ __ ] okay so
hold on so anywhere in asia if you're
white you are a [ __ ] landmark people
want to take pictures with you is that's
what i want to ask you but okay so
that's interesting because i have
friends that have um canadian and us
and they'll travel with the canadians
sure because people [ __ ] hate us
everywhere else totally not true people
love us we have money and we [ __ ] tip
in places where there is no tips people
love us the traveler wants people love
they don't love our policies or some
[ __ ] sure they love us what a terrible i
was [ __ ] when we were kids people
were saying that no way okay uh-uh so
you were here they hate in terms of
backpackers australians they get drunk
and throw up too much they're fun but
they go too hard and
chinese tourists are the worst tourists
in the world they'll say no they'll be
straight races to those like you can't
be here and russians always fight
but americans irish canadians they love
all of us okay we're just bringing money
third world countries they lo it's like
yeah we don't know prices so you're
you're saying you're like a celebrity oh
yeah but also like asian blonde girls
they're just they line up literally line
up to take pictures with them we saw one
girl in myanmar somewhere else in bagan
yeah i'm gone
lana and then one girl got back in line
she changed her shirt and got back in
line yeah because they're blondes these
blonde girls from canada who are on gap
year yeah yeah they line up to take
pictures i had somebody ask me to hold
their baby once
so it's like it takes you actually white
skin it's so they're like what the [ __ ]
especially from a small town if you're
from like beijing or like one of the
biggest that you've seen them but half
of beijing or tourists from that's what
they were saying
[Laughter]
we walked in that market in that town
uh well i'll tell you that later but
like anywhere you go it's it's nuts
they're just like they've never seen it
they've never seen anything like it my
dad told me they used to do that in like
germany when like american gis would go
down the road like in the suburbs and
stuff they would all stop and just come
out of their our houses like post like
60s and 70s just like they just never
seen one can you imagine never having
seen a race white person yeah well yeah
you're right well i have sure i haven't
seen some races out there
probably some eyes like vijay singh i
don't think i've seen that color whoever
that is you know he's like wasn't black
or brown or gray
he was like his own color
i've never seen one of those in person
it's like
oh that's good it's like an ash is still
on the log
or something what is that
where is he from it's not india it's
different from india
it's a reason i don't know
oh
[ __ ] yeah but that's how they feel about
us so
so who is that look of like what because
we also are in that place where it's
like
but we didn't know that we didn't know
you weren't allowed to go there we were
just like why don't we go there people
like don't like why they're like that's
not where you go you go around
we were just like you're an idiot wrong
anytime i've second guessed any other
culture
they handed out barf bags and these
teamwork going up to these roads and
they hand up and they're like wow i've
been taking the buses but i'm like why
do you give them to locals i can see why
you give them to me i couldn't handle it
but why and then i'm like oh they're
trash bags to throw your trash out but
then halfway up the road everyone just
throws their trash right out the window
with impunity just they don't care at
all and so i'm like
oh their own country dude and you see it
just like line all the train tracks and
all the roads just trash oh there's so
much trash meanwhile and then you're
like why do they ha and then they just
start barfing in them even the locals
the locals yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah
what does that smell like not great oh
not great it's okay until the ac ac
moves and then it's like well there it
is
yeah it's not great because it's in time
it's the entire thing and how hot is it
no
it's tremendously hot outside 95 with
like 98 humidity inside maybe 35 degrees
now they crank the ac crazy they give
you a blanket when you get in so it's
that hot [ __ ] 11 p.m when i got on my
first bus and they were like with shorts
they're like no you can't wear that in
here i'm like what are you talking about
why and they're like nah and they made
me put pants on which i didn't get until
the [ __ ] started blasting and then
for four hours it's like you could see
your breath legitimately you could see
it bro it's not 35 degrees it's like 45
50 degrees
yeah and then like they stop for a rest
and you [ __ ] run out and warm up a
little it's i don't know why they do it
why didn't none of them complain
they just go those levels just like well
anyway
so we get there there's just staring at
us and we're like all right this is like
but like
uh i guess we must have learned the word
for like sleep and then one guy gets up
and goes behind the counter
and was like just looking at us from
there
two rooms
there's three dudes and we're like you
know [ __ ] caught
and um and he goes uh
and he's like
no
like what do you mean two rooms and
we're like the rooms you know we just
kept pointing us though like it's the
room we want to sleep here asleep here
he was just staring and then he like
left and went talk to those other two
guys
and then he
he made a phone call he got on his phone
and he was just like
talking for a while and then um
and then some other guy comes in from
outside damn i haven't thought about
this in a long time some other guy comes
from my side with broken broken english
and he goes you cannot stay here and
we're like what do you mean it's a hotel
right he goes yeah
it's but no you can't stay here like why
what are you talking about none of this
makes sense is there another hotel like
you can't stay you just kept saying you
can't stay here and then
at some point they must have made more
phone calls and talk the hotel phone
rang and it was somebody from yangon
from the capitol and she was like you're
not allowed to stay there there's no
foreigners allowed to stay there and
we're like well we got off the bus
and she goes you have to turn around
where'd you come from the south she goes
turn around go south we just came from
the south we're going north because
no the next bus north isn't coming today
and you can't stay there and so then we
did a three day do you know why you
can't no i don't i didn't know about the
[ __ ] rohingya until way after i got
home and i was telling people how much
fun i had in memory in this culture it
wasn't as bad as this now but they're
like oh i bet you had fun while they
were wiping out mothers and children and
you're like nah i didn't see any of that
they wouldn't let us
i just saw a lot of like weird foot
volleyball but like uh
yeah so um
yeah they wouldn't even let us what do
you mean they hide it you so they had a
capital they had all the protests during
the couple years years decades before
and um they got sick of the of uh all
the [ __ ] protests so they just move
their capital the middle of the country
it's the middle of nowhere and so then
people they didn't want to go all the
way there
yeah
they changed their name it was burma and
then the military's like we got a bad
name
we're just it's now myanmar that was
like 20 years ago
it's the same country
yeah they just took over so how do you
get out of there then okay so i was like
what about a a a monastery we can sleep
at a monastery
which they're supposed to take you in we
slept in one we were hiking one day you
stayed at like a village another day you
say to monastery and cold but like
everyone bundles up someone's like i
know i can just go there and they'll let
me like sleep on the floor and she just
started laughing she was like no way you
have to turn around what are you talking
about
and i was like i'm allowed to sleep with
the monster i thought i just started
crying on the phone it wasn't a real cry
but i let myself get there i i was like
in that moment you know all the acting
classes in l.a kicked in i got like we
can't meanwhile i could have just hired
a cab for like 250 bucks to take us all
the way back there but you got to live
like a backpacker you got to live like
everybody else what's your back what's
your budget daily
whoever's
in our group whoever their budget is
that's my budget so if i'm like if i'm
like
i like staying in hostels because it's
like it's more social
um
like i don't have to but it's so much
more social you find out stuff to do you
make friends oh they're like real
travelers nobody makes friends at hotels
they're not robbing you left and right
no [ __ ]
you might you might get yourself stolen
yeah but again i got a parachute of i
i'm not
trying to travel for a year on i'm 10
grand you know yeah i could i could
you know that song common people by pulp
yeah i can always call my dad
you know the cockroaches on their wall
that was me man but you don't make me
feel bad so you don't be like we're all
going to steak dinner
and get weird right you know
but if i was like in a place for one day
on my way to somewhere else like i had
to get on a plane
i'm staying like a nice hotel i'm not
going to meet anybody i want a real
shower what's your where does this come
from is anyone in your family like this
the need to get away and want to see
different things because you don't just
go but you don't go to italy and you
don't go you know you really yeah you
take
the great wall i was telling you about
before i remember your giant it opened
it up for me it was the most foreign
place i've ever been to the first place
that was the first one 2014. that great
was that the great wall that was on that
trip yeah yeah dez bishop was like a
chinese comedian then
um
and he was like i'll set you up with a
trip there not much and then you just go
up there forever and it was the whole
but the whole all of beijing and
shanghai was just like it's just so
different you can't they don't they
don't take the bones out of their
chinese chop it up yeah so you're eating
and you're like looking at like what the
[ __ ] there's bones in the thing it's
suppose it's pieces
they just chop it with a mallet and then
[ __ ] cook it and serve it you're like
what
and i'm looking at it and this lady
comes by and she brings me a fork
because i wasn't shy i was a tour i'm
like no i know how to do it i'm staring
at your food
the ability to pick it up
yeah it was nuts you would walk by so if
you leave like the center area in
shanghai that was the first first place
dude i walked with andy uh with um with
turner sparks he picked me up from the
airport in shanghai i've never been i've
been to europe a little bit israel but
like it's all little americas you know
it's all pretty much the same i get what
you're saying slight difference you go
to australia the birds beaks are
different but yeah
so we're going down an alley we get out
of the airport airport looks the same as
anything we get out we're going down an
alley you see all the people you talking
about the chinese bikini which is just
you go like this and you walk around
with just like that and just like that's
what dude dudes do all the time so we're
walking and we see some guy some beggar
and he goes uh don't look at that don't
look at that by the way
and um
zero chance i'm not gonna look at that
yeah at that point right there was a
chance i wouldn't have looked at it but
no way when you tell me not to look it
there's no way no
so i looked at it
so this dude was on the ground his leg
um
yellowish spot this wide
right sorry
then inside that purple
there and then inside that exposed bone
oh
[ __ ] and it's just sitting out on the
street just like that he's just out
there begging for nickels or whatever
oh
[ __ ] yeah straight bone
boom yeah it was out he was he was yeah
he's done he gotta assume he's he didn't
yeah that was 2014. that guy didn't
survive covet no way did that guy get
seen first at the hospital
[Laughter]
we deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies and why especially when it
comes to something we take every day
rituals clean vegan-friendly
multivitamin is formulated with high
quality nutrients in bioavailable forms
your body can actually use and what you
won't find
sugars gmos major allergens synthetic
fillers and artificial colorants plus
the fresh taste and the laid release
capsule design makes taking your
vitamins easy you guys hear me talk
about ritual all the time i'm a proud
ritual taker take it every day and i can
tell you even with my taste messed up i
could taste the minty fresh in it it's
pretty nice it comes right in my mailbox
every month you can put it on pause you
can start stop whenever you want rituals
made traceable so you'll always know
what nutrients you're taking and where
they come from thanks to rituals
one-of-a-kind visible supply chain
rituals designed with your life stage in
mind it's now available for women men
and teens ritual multivitamins are
scientifically developed to help support
different life stages ritual makes
healthy habits easy your multivitamins
are delivered like i told you right to
your door every month with free shipping
always you can start snooze or cancel
your subscription anytime and if you
don't love ritual within your first
month they'll refund your first order
get key nutrients without the bs ritual
is offering my listeners 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
honeydew to start your ritual today
there's so much going on in the world
right now whether it's stuff you're
excited about like the night pants
nation tour get your tickets at
ryancicle.com or stuff you'd rather not
think about like not going out on tour
get your tickets available at
ryancichler.com you can't always control
the vibes out there but you can always
control the vibes in your head with a
pair of raycon wireless earbuds in your
ears look i listen to podcasts i listen
to the honeydew we all should be
listening to in your ray cons and music
i make playlists for me my daughter and
i love my raicons i travel with them i
exercise with them
so whether you use them to pump up wind
down work or work out raycons are my
go-to for on-the-go audio and the new
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever with an improved rubber
oil look and feel and optimize gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit these are
impressive before you even start
listening like that little tip they've
got little ones you can i don't know if
you've done this yet you can try them
fit them in there and everything they
fit tight they hold in they don't fall
out on my ear even when i bend over and
stuff tilt to the side nothing i still
wear some old pairs every now and then
snag on my my kitchen counters and
everything else all right so you get
three new sound profiles to make sure
everything you're listening to sounds
it's best with just the right amount of
bass there's a pure mode for podcast
listening like the honeydew blues
instrumental there's a balance mode
again podcast listening like the
honeydew rock heavy rock and metal and
then you got your base mode for hip-hop
edm reggae etc right there's also an
all-new awareness mode for when you need
to listen to your surroundings instead
raycons offer eight hours of play time
and a 32-hour battery life there's also
a built-in mic and you could take calls
on your earbuds at the press of a button
raycon start at half the price of other
premium audio brands but they sound just
as good and raycons come with a 45 day
happiness guarantee right now honeydew
listeners can get fifteen percent off
their raycon order at buyracon.com
honeydew that's byracon.com honeydew to
save fifteen percent on your rate cons
by raycon.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do so
anyway but then you just like you like
walk you see a grill there's just meat
of some kind and you're just like i
don't want give them the equivalent of
like 60 cents and they give you like two
um kebabs and you're just like if you
don't like it [ __ ] chuck it you know
it's just so fun it was just so [ __ ]
weird there old men sweeping with like
palm leaf brooms just like hired by the
government like everyone is i guess oh
really i guess so they have capital i
don't really i don't know i don't really
know about their system but they have
capitalism but also like
i don't know everybody works i don't
know how you've never been robbed or oh
so they told me it was the safest city
you'll ever go to they said women can
pass out drunk on the street no one will
touch them it's and once they told me
that that's what unleashed it they told
me that and i was like wait what it was
the americans and whatever canadians who
lived there telling me that i was like
oh
well then i have nothing to worry so
then it's like get out there
if you're telling me no there's no
violence you were you were a little
hesitant at first and then yeah and then
once you hear that you're in yeah and
then they were like you're the first one
we brought out here that was like no no
i'm good today let's go i'll you know
i'll just get out there he said schubert
was always like come on need to rock
help me and i'm like i'll just point to
a [ __ ] menu item and whatever they
bring it's fine yeah it costs nothing
out there nothing costs anything out
there
it's all
like 12 cents to 30 cents so if you
don't like something just [ __ ] chuck
it man you're not committed to anything
yeah yeah
i learned the word for beef
um
uh
rio i think something like that i doubt
that's still it that many years ago but
like um
neo maybe something like that but anyway
and then it'd be like ask for beef and
then which one i like which one i'm like
ah number three it's just fun i don't
know it's great it's so much fun out
there
especially when nothing's gonna hurt you
so yeah that's i mean where do you hear
that yeah where do you hear that music
festivals that's it
yeah
well not the woodstock ones and [ __ ]
we're hearing about uh-huh not that
[ __ ] documentary you see that the
bathing and [ __ ] yeah
um
so have you been robbed right now no
never but if i did i'd just be like it
won't cost that much you gotta go with
new underwear
socks
but where are you going to get stuff
like that
stores
this is doors it's not jungles oh you're
not going out to remote places
no one so i was in cambodia once in my
flip-flops whatever and they just don't
have an eleven and a half so those my
flip-flops were done there's all these
sizes yeah and they were like no they're
like try to fit into a 10.
um and you're like no what do you mean
like it's my feet are way over the edge
and they're like it'll stretch i'm like
not the
the top part stretches not like the
flip-flops never stretch
but you just can't find an 11 and a half
and then when i finally found one it was
like a knock-off version of like a
i don't know some surf brand but
immediately the things started like
break so you just got to staple it like
you got to make [ __ ] work it's fun to
like have things to overcome you know
like little like problems
i just had to find glue and
glue up my my flip-flops anyway so we're
in this [ __ ] place they're all
staring at us you know and they're like
she was like you can't i don't tell you
you can't stay there i'm like well we're
not going south and she goes well hold
on let me figure it out like don't go
anywhere but also like you can't stay
here so we go to the market as we go
around on the market
my buddy from seattle they're just like
he's stopping the market it's just like
like
card after card after card after card
you know rows of that and they it's like
the wave in baseball they just stop
everything as soon as this white guy
comes you can just see them all look up
and like what the until he's about gone
and then back to the [ __ ] sewing
whatever it is and he just shut it down
and then the line form to take pictures
pictures yeah
i got a hat there that i still have a
sweet-ass hat that i didn't know what it
meant in burmese it says chill out
[ __ ] perfect there you go yeah
um
anyway we go back and uh and this lady's
like all right there's a man who's in
another hotel she gets back on the phone
and he's willing to take you in at his
hotel we're like okay yeah but like what
do you mean take us in that's not like
it's
like you're on the underground railroad
right now yeah yeah
and she goes but he's doing it out of
the goodness of his heart like he's not
supposed to
and we're like uh all right he goes so
do you understand that that guy's doing
you a favor and like should we pay him
more no but that's like this is our
culture to help people it is that's what
they always said like it's part of their
culture to help people so he's helping
you
like okay
so we go there he takes us in we get two
rooms
two reds and one one better than another
um
and then we go out we're like hey
there's a on the on the map there's a
there's a thing called statue so let's
go see it's right near an army base so
we're looking at the statue of just like
an old army guy
after like 20 30 minutes we're taking
some pictures about four one guy in
front four guys behind him with machine
guns come out and then just come right
we're like interesting they just walked
right out of the army barracks and then
right up to us and like what are you
guys doing here
and we're like they they're speaking
english fine yeah the [ __ ] out
absolutely
yeah absolutely
what are you doing here and i was like
well we're just like we're on our way to
it's up north
stopped him for the night he was like
why are you taking pictures of any of
this and we're like i don't know it's
just a statue we just thought of it like
let me see your phone delete delete
delete immediately not his phone it's
camera
um because not allowed to take pictures
of any of this like okay we're sorry
where are your passports
and like but they're back in the room
let's go get em
and so it was about a mile walk through
the city with these four machine gun
guys to your backs yeah [ __ ]
are people looking at you extra now that
you're white and you got machine guns to
your back you would think
but no
they were not they're mine their [ __ ]
business yeah
that's that don't look don't look don't
you yeah yeah yeah they don't wanna you
wanna
you're testing my loyalties
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they're taking you back to the dude
that's doing you the favor yeah to get
your passport yes so all this later i
understand the foreigners are not
allowed to stay there the army has
control of everything there are rebel
groups that are fighting back against
the army and then there's different
factions who are siding with different
rebel groups one rebel group said if you
give us some level of freedom army we'll
side with you and we'll try to get these
other rebel groups
to stop fighting you so like go between
groups
anyway bottom line is they don't want us
there at all and each rebel group is
like really good at protecting their own
area
so anyway showing the passport takes off
don't come back to the statue which i
didn't we didn't we were like okay i
guess we learned our lesson
uh everybody's having fun now at this
point it's all cool again we're playing
like [ __ ] uh they have this weird uh
volleyball kick volleyball game they
just like kick this ball up wicker um
yeah it's sick to see but like uh
constantly i like doing bicycle kicks
yeah and they get their legs and they're
so good down on it
it's not a full-size net you've seen it
yeah i've seen it online yeah yeah
yeah
my buddy took this picture that i gotta
blow up it's it's [ __ ] a perfect one
of it
um
damn but uh yeah so we played that for a
while everybody loved playing with the
whites they thought it was so [ __ ]
like come on oh my god
look they're trying it yeah my buddy was
from newcastle yeah my buddy was a big
newcastle fan so he was like he was good
the wrestler was like you like [ __ ]
try you know you get one up and they run
after it they know how to do it where it
goes behind them and they're catching on
the flat of their foot
it's nutty i saw a guy do a one-on-three
in yangon he fought three other fought
he played three other guys and beat him
and beat him kick and they were good
this guy was a straight monkey dude he
was just like he was small he had just a
diaper on and that's it no yeah a diaper
like a cloth diaper yeah yeah a diaper
yeah
i'll show you a picture i have a picture
of it
um i mean it was just like tied cloth
like you know
whatever
anyway we're having fun go eat um uh do
you know what so if they're not allowed
to keep us there that's why i'm thinking
right now she's like that guy is putting
himself in danger by having you there
i thought anyway yeah [ __ ] harriet
tubman over there
yeah he might have got in serious
trouble
yeah he might have been like what
the last thing i want i'm on the other
side of town you brought the army here
you brought the army i told them i was
disobeying your rules
are you you could not have done a worse
job it's like when someone trust you
with the secret and you killed the
person yeah oh that's the one you told
me
damn well that guy's been killed for
sure
sorry dudes widow uh i apologize for oh
yeah hopefully you sell the hotel
[ __ ] i got terrible food poisoning that
night too i had to barf [ __ ] combo on a
on a no toilet toilet where you just put
your feet down and there's a hole in the
hole so you got to pull your projectile
vomiting forward and [ __ ] at the
same time yeah you gotta like yeah you
gotta lean and then we're like guess
which one guess which one and then like
put your knees on that [ __ ] [ __ ]
floor piss floor uh oh
god
you have these pills you gotta take but
you gotta keep it down
so it's like when am i gonna start
barfing oh god
that was a terrible one
anyway we stayed there
got better whatever that drug is
supposed to take um
not
toxicity azithromycin
never go to these places without a z
pack which is three pills of
azithromycin take one comes down the
next day take another one and as you
start bubbling up again food poisoning
is
you're gonna get it if you're out there
yeah but just like try to minimize it
and dry you out yeah you get yeah like
nick molly said a joke about how
diarrhea is to kill you so people used
to be like it's not funny
people are dying of this
but like uh
yeah and then the next one so then we
left and i [ __ ]
that got that he had a key i [ __ ]
took it with me by accident
no
i found it on the train
i found the train in the next city and
i'm like ah [ __ ]
i mean he really helped us out again i'm
sorry widow of that guy outside
yeah i don't know it's just fun it's
just fun being free and trying to like
just figure [ __ ] out well what about
hiking in south america like those are
fun what do you like you but don't you
purposely use in general what no phone
didn't you go no phone and everything in
southeast asia that's what it was i i
called uber i then i threw it when as
soon as i was like yeah we got you threw
my phone in the drawer and then went out
with my [ __ ] and just like i locked
myself out of my uh email my um on
purpose on purpose facebook and
everything else instagram i just gave it
to a friend i just went like this i
remember abram was answering for you and
stuff like that some of the stuff yeah i
was like contact him if you needed about
this
um what was that like how long were you
without that kind of uh
three and a half months maybe months it
was that long what was that like that's
like back living in the 80s again it was
the most freeing thing i've ever done
there was no connection there was there
was nothing clogging your brain
there was just
nothing other than what am i going to do
today
some loose plans
but like nobody's bothering with gossip
it's just
it's just so like
free you're just floating
you're like i'm gonna go to that so i
i got to this city in me i mean i say
because my first like crazy place i went
to was myanmar after china that was the
first like hostility i did and that was
the first i was like just out there with
like no connection so landed went to
yangon for a while and then i was going
to go to
like a temple city or this other city up
north and the temple city busted already
left so i'm like i'll go to the city up
north
get there and i say i want to i want to
catch the this old train that everybody
wants to one of the tourist things to do
get a ticket on this old train that
takes you all it takes is over this
massive aqueduct supposed to be really
cool
can i get there like sold out tomorrow i
was like [ __ ] so i didn't even took a
nap at the hostel and i just went south
to the temple city but the freedom of
being able to go like then i'll just
switch my plans it doesn't seem like a
lot but when you're just constantly
zero responsibility yeah i mean you're a
dad yeah so you have way more than i do
right now yeah yeah
but that's what i'm saying you're doing
it right like if i could pack up and
just bust out i'd go yeah i'd go
segura one time when i was moving to new
york he was like uh he goes i wish i
could move to new york and i was like
why don't you buddy
like he was doing
possibly worse than me then
if that's possible it might have been
he was already headlining
nah he had to be go ahead and be that
but it was close anyway we're on the
same level and um and he was like yeah i
wish i could uh and i was like what do
you mean you're a comic just you can you
can just go because now i'm [ __ ]
married before you have kids for sure
he's like i'm married i don't know i
gotta move two people and i was like
[ __ ] and then i put in my head i'm like
i gotta start making people like tom
sugar jealous
you know i gotta i'm not gonna play xbox
all day and just do nothing i'm like oh
look at the [ __ ] single guy
so like you know live for that and so
with that mindset it's like oh just try
[ __ ] it's so fun out there so you get
out there and you're like there's
nothing to do i can go any direction i
could leave what are you also going into
like these hikes without any real
experience or anything no in myanmar
after some country somebody's like i
heard after that temple city someone's
like i heard there's a three-day hike
you can go on
it's guided yeah they have they get a
guide in that town and they'll take you
and it's it's three days with the same
eight people a tourist and this guy who
led us and it's it's just like i've
never done anything like that you'd hike
with your [ __ ] on you
and just go and then where do you sleep
you put first night in a 10 minutes in a
no some place took us in so it was like
a big
a big thatch wood room and then
connected to another big thatcher roof
room and the roof went over both there's
a fire in the other one
and the smoke heats up everything
and makes you not able to breathe all
night long i'll kind of say yeah it's
all carbon monoxide or whatever yeah but
that's what your heat is
and um
went out to go take a piss before the
sun rose and that was by even zion that
was the best stars i've ever seen up in
the mountains in myanmar
and then the moon came and washed all
the way it was it was just like bright
like you get out and you're just like
what
yeah then hiked all day the next day
um
put some water whatever go through a
village or two or town there's some
soccer game in the mountains it's just
so weird and like
i don't know out there
bought these like cigars they they sell
you and i was like i just want like two
and they were like no here's like 200
it's like a pack of them it's like and
i'm like no i just want to try one
like it's 20 cents for the 200 you're
like yeah i'll just give them out
yeah but this hike was so cool we ended
up doing that same group met in the alps
and we're like let's go hiking again so
there's one in ecuador same thing like a
four-day hike from one place
um to another coming home and then going
back to the separator the whole time
you're doing you're staying over there
and going from staying in the major to
ecuador oh no no no those are all
separate trips asia's one trip went to
went to um
my friend in austria those guys again
like another trip that was just went to
munich went start in austria then you
take a ski lift at the mountain and you
just stay up there for five six days
just like you hike from hostile hut to
heights the hostile hut you have like a
backpack on you all your [ __ ]
are you ever running into any kind of
wildlife or anything some gophers that
scream
yeah there's nothing up there it's dead
it's out it's so high up there and some
birds
but yeah it's fun and freeing and just
like out nature and stuff so we did the
same one in ecuador we were already
there we heard about one
cooper's big crater lake
so it's like day after day there's hiker
hostels up there separate rooms or
whatever but they give you wood and a
fire metal fireplace
some nice some really dank but like
there's a route that people have taken
so it's me
uh my partner
and this other guy that i met once um
who's like from there a white dude but
he like spent time then he was there and
he was like and we were like all right
we're bored quarantined so it's just the
two of us and our dog you know so we're
like yeah come along you know
so
we start hiking we buy enough equipment
to go it's cold and [ __ ] but it's also
hot during the day and it's the
mountains so
i'd say
late first day
um
six to eight hours hiking every day
probably six six hours into the first
day yeah it's a lot the first day i was
think was only five so it was like four
hours in i realized i hated that other
guy
[Music]
the new dude yeah
he wasn't he was annoying
oh that sucks yeah he talked about
himself a lot it was annoying um but i
didn't want to say anything i want to
ruin it i didn't tell my partner that
it was just like suck it up because
we're not going anywhere the car's back
there
we're gonna get a
ride when we get to where we're going
this crater lake
back
you know that'll take a few hours but
this is taking through the mountains and
it's days so i'm like i can't there's
nothing i can do i can't say shut the
[ __ ] up right quit talking bragging with
every [ __ ] breath
but i don't want to say anything so
and do you tell on these walks and talks
are you telling them what you do
yeah he knows me he does yeah he knows
who you are like we we've met yeah yeah
we've met because you're a comic and all
that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
but
so it's like what am i there's nothing
to do we're doing this i've known by
it's like we're not walking off so you
got to make the best of it you know
that's a rule for sure make the best of
it
if you [ __ ] miss the plane or the bus
just like take a minute you can mourn
you can put yourself up for a second
don't just look who cares like let
yourself care but then like now what
yeah all right so i'm in some town this
will be cool stay here for an extra day
let's see if there's a barbecue you know
something
so i'm not going to tell my part i'm not
going to soil this for anybody else so
um
day two is acid day we're like let's
drop some acid and walk which i was like
and walk yeah okay how much acid do you
take a gel tab which i've never taken a
gel tab before yeah i've never heard of
that one yeah
good idea though
my dog's loving it up there by the way
just run i mean if we hiked for six
hours a day he was doing double
everything run it off anytime he sees
like a deer or a [ __ ] frog just run
he's loving it god damn he's never been
that happy
for many people in the u.s concerned
about the cost of health insurance there
are no good options so you either go
uninsured or you pay through the nose
for a high deductible plan with
questionable coverage all because of a
broken health insurance system it's like
being stuck with an outdated cable tv
plan and not knowing about netflix
introducing crowd health it isn't health
insurance it's a better way to pay
medical expenses crowd health is a
community of people who are tired of
paying for a broken system a place where
you can get a simple flexible and
affordable way to pay for your health
care being in the crowd health community
can save hundreds of dollars monthly and
put thousands of dollars back in your
pocket membership as a monthly
subscription is flexible you can start
or stop when it's convenient for you
crowdhealth lowers your monthly
healthcare costs and you can see any
doctor you want it's simple scan bills
and throw them away crowd health takes
it from there 100 of your monthly
membership pays for actual health care
costs helping the whole crowd health
community stay healthy while keeping
more money in your pocket crowd health
is able to offer amazing prices because
of its community of health conscious
members but they have an amazing offer
just for my listeners get your first six
months for just 99
per month that's a savings of almost 50
percent versus their standard pricing
and a lot less than one of those crappy
high deductible plans just go to
joincrowdhealth.com 99 and enter code
honeydew at sign up that's join
crowdhealth.com
99 promo code honeydew crowd health is
not health insurance it's a
community-powered alternative term and
conditions may apply look the cost of
rent these days is ridiculous and buying
your first home can feel daunting
unrealistic confusing i've never done it
i'm not a homeowner i still rent i go
out here looking in la
people paying over asking price with
cash don't worry about fixing it up
we'll take it now we'll buy that
perfectly good house we're going to
destroy it and then build a mansion on
top of it all right it's so competitive
that's why i highly recommend listening
to the how to buy a home podcast the how
to buy home podcast is essentially a
free playbook of the do's and don'ts to
buying your first home no matter if
you're clueless on how to start or deep
deepen the mess looking for clarity host
david sidone is an industry insider with
years of experience who actually cares
about first-time home buyers and wants
to help them beat a system that is
rigged against them he answers questions
like do i really need to put 20 down
answer is no most people only need to
put 3.5 and david will tell you how look
i talked to him on the phone okay he
wasn't like other people just you know
this that he really is talking to you
and giving you advice on how to do it
all right i'm actually going to talk to
him have a consultation with him because
i want to know he's like you can do it
for what you pay in rent you can buy a
home trust me talk to me listen to the
show so
i'm telling you if you're thinking about
buying a home next month next year in
five years listen to the how to buy home
podcast today this is your best bet to
avoid being one of those horror stories
and get an insider playbook with clear
no bs real information find how to buy a
home wherever you listen to podcasts now
let's get back to the duke
anyway ass is kicking in we're fine it's
[ __ ] loopy i can handle my [ __ ]
so
i i expect everyone else to handle their
[ __ ] as well
and if you can't [ __ ] say something
yeah just [ __ ] hey i need help here
whatever don't but
when we went to that theme park yeah did
you oh did you not feel it didn't feel
it didn't feel it yeah edibles
yeah
your neighbors got [ __ ] up and out of
red
yeah you were fine yeah edibles don't
[ __ ] work on me
diaz gave me one one time he gave me the
star of death and i would eat it
and then he's like you don't need that
[ __ ] i'm like i ate it you got
cameras go back and look i ate it right
on camera and then i come the next time
and it was uh two stars of death so i
eat two stars of death and nothing he
didn't believe you so then he comes to
um remember when we had atc was at that
uh
raleigh studios remember that
so he came there and he's like eat this
in front of me again and i just sit
there i chew it he's like show me your
tongue and i swallow it and then does
not believe you and at the end of it he
like it was like he was upset he's like
so
it really sucks to still do something to
you i go yeah i don't know i probably
have to do like three of them and then
i'll get so [ __ ] far out i don't want
him you know what i mean like that's not
the point so i go back one more time
this [ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ] he
gave me this [ __ ] look like
black tar heroin i was like
yeah let me use the bathroom real quick
i threw that [ __ ] and i was like
a personal challenge yeah he
you should you should yeah you should
not trust diaz when he gets like no he's
like
yeah they're they don't really they
don't work i give them to everybody
that's crazy that one other person like
you i believe you yeah i mean i'll do
his 10 milligrams [ __ ] or whatever he'll
give me the 20 and i forget i even took
it i forgot i even took it yeah
you might be an x-man
i don't know about that what if that was
your x-men power it can't be better
i just want to be i just
from underwater i got to be at the
academy and [ __ ] like that's all you get
well you do give him all your [ __ ]
weed man nothing
he won't get buried
flames like that's amazing
wow
hold your edibles anyway
so kicking in having a great time in
nature i mean the ass is perfect
um
midway through that day my partner's
like scrumbles about something and i was
like we just looked at each other
and i looked at him he looked at me and
was just like
we made that connection that you can
make with a loved one and it's just like
i'm not talking about it but it's just a
i finally got there
what you've been feeling it's like
whenever it like come it came like an
hour
which
so then in the hotel in not the hotel
the hot hot car hostel that one on top
of whatever
um
it was like hey
he's annoying right
he's annoying and it was like okay we
can't we're still on this for two more
days we can't
save it all
and we'll deal with it later but like we
can it's gonna be horrible for us if we
say anything or if we really start to
hate him if we talk too much [ __ ] then
we're not gonna even enjoy anything he
does you know so it's like sure he's
braggadocious but like
we can still enjoy moments and that
evaporated completely the next step
i mean
it was just what was it do you remember
anything that sticks in your head the
line from him yeah okay yeah so we go in
an overlook right it's where it's like
you're in the mountains so sometimes
just beautiful view something's not
there's a beautiful view and we go down
there and like you look you're like wow
and just like you sit there for a while
like this is just amazing you know it's
just it's just like when you get a bluff
it's just like it takes your breath away
man that's awesome
we're looking we're like that's cool
let's walk back and then he goes out
there and then we're like walking and
talk sitting down smoking a j probably
or
or getting water whatever he comes back
he's
did you guys um see that overlook like
yeah we both just did yeah for sure
whatever you're about to say we also saw
it right because you're like i found the
best like we were just there like we
came around from the other way so he was
like
i would describe that feeling as
orgasmic and we're like
come on
i would come i'll shove this
[ __ ] off the side
you would have dude you would not have
held your tongue on this guy
like no one's gonna suspect
i'll be like you know what guys i'm
apologizing advance right now listen
[ __ ] god damn it was annoying
we're not sure we're in nature i've
never been in nature like that you
usually you're like i could i would
welcome a talk at the end of the day
because we've been quiet enjoying the
birds and the bees and the insects and
the noise and the babbling
and so then what i do is when i get
anyone i don't know how you are if
there's like
maybe a young comic or a fan who's like
wants it too bad
so this helps me not to bother anybody
famous you know i just walk away if i'm
not gonna talk to him i don't want to
like annoy anybody so i'm just walking
away anybody i like really respect i'm
like and then i just go
if they want a conversation and it's
like maybe you just got off stage and
you're like i want to talk right now but
you can't say i want to talk right now
so you just kind of get quiet and you
hope you're quiet will make them like
match [ __ ] you know emotions with you
and it does something and then sometimes
they want to fill in that silence so
they just talk more and more and more
and that makes me shrivel up more and
more and more so that's what i'm doing
i'm just shriveling up because i can't
talk back because i don't [ __ ] care
he's such a [ __ ] so band was playing
with like a with like a uh he saw a frog
he'd just go over there he's a vegan and
[ __ ] like that so he's like looking at
this frog and we're like hey man look at
the frog and he goes no he's gonna kill
it like dude first of all that's goddamn
major second of all
he's gonna play with this [ __ ] frog
relax also one [ __ ] frog down calm
down if it happens
a one down hey what do you want to
practice on a baby for the first weird
thing he's seen let him see the frog
if he comes back with a frog in his
mouth that's just a new trick
anyway
so the acid was the hardest part because
okay
i'm sorry i got it wrong acid was the
last day
okay asked it was the last day does it
make it worse no because we were even
thinking like maybe we shouldn't take
this asset this last day and we were
like yeah for sure let's do that because
then the next day would be hiking around
the crater so last days getting to the
top second day is like a long long down
up whatever we'd already decided we're
this the ass is going to help us we talk
about set and setting you know we're
like maybe there's a net let's just
laugh about it emotionally we can
[ __ ] communicate through the [ __ ]
heavens and we'll like deal with it
together bandit doesn't know bandit
loves everybody
so
so the last day he decides to take his
shoes off
um it gets them really wet it was
raining
a lot of it so we had like ponchos but
it was raining for a lot of it which
makes it miserable it's just not fun
you try to find shelter for a while but
like at some point like you gotta get
going because you're in nature you're
nothing so you gotta get to that hiker
meanwhile every once in a while like
once per day it's a [ __ ] old
ecuadorian couple with just [ __ ] 70
groceries on their head would just
[ __ ] lap us for real yeah it's like
hello he's like talk for a minute
tony would be like would be like say
something to him like in spanish
and then just like anyway see and then
just go like what the [ __ ] because they
would tell how long it was supposed to
take and we're like we're doing double
this they're talking about ecuadorians
they don't even rest ever they'll go to
rest stops
anyway
ron acid takes his shoes off and he goes
it's really great the feel of the
[ __ ] soil
on your feet which i get i've been to
festivals where people have done that
they've like these shoes i don't need
them anymore great whatever you guys
should do it nah but you go for it i
like my [ __ ] waterproof merrells
you know
they're dry on the inside i've hiked a
long time they're dry my feet are dry
and he's like i got it you try to hike
with sneakers that was your mistake
he just keeps pushing it gods feel so
good take your shoes off like i don't
know man it's not gonna happen
you should do it like okay you keep
saying that but i don't want to in any
way
eventually like hey i'm not i'm gonna
take my shoes off so there's no way
there's literally no way you should stop
saying well i'm just enjoying i was like
fine
an hour later he's like dude i can't
feel my toes
it's cold and i've been walking on rocks
for far too long i can feel my toes i'm
like put your [ __ ] shoes back on
that's the number one reason you can't
feel your teeth
[Laughter]
it's cold and rainy and rocky and i get
it it was sandy back there three hours
ago why are you sticking to this
the trails are hard to to read they're
not well marked um especially after cova
they probably stopped maintaining them
we get a bit lost we don't really know
where we are we're on some other trail
to who knows where we have a map from
the last hostel hand-drawn map so it's
like
dude if we don't get to then we're just
sleeping in like 45 degree rain outside
so we got to get somewhere there's very
few farms even out there
the ones that are speak like
maybe spanish maybe quechua so like even
the [ __ ] guy who knows how to speak
spanish might not be able to communicate
with him
and not many of those and how are we
gonna be like can i sleep in your
[ __ ] barn you know so we're getting
lost this guy it's like he's never done
[ __ ] acid before because he is just
gone going like you have to feel the
[ __ ] nah
he took his shoes back off
already they're back off already and he
goes you gotta feel i'm like hey we got
to follow this map we got to figure out
this map we've been gone for maybe an
hour off the road i don't know where we
are and we're both like hey and he's
like come play with me and we're like
dude it was just like hey we're getting
to look like ignore that guy we need we
are at least an hour out of the way and
it's getting dark at some point soon
so he's like no let's just try let's
just go that's what he said let's just
go man i forgot about all this let's
just walk and like no that's not gonna
work dude we can't just walk
we're gonna die so like
so we're like all right i think it's
back there i think we maybe if we missed
that turn if that's what it was these
random marks like a big set of rocks
turn left and you're like okay but then
you're like there's lots of those
so if that was where we missed it
then we got like an hour to go back
we're already two hours behind schedule
now it's like
so like what do you think we should do
because if we go back and it's not the
right way then we [ __ ] ourselves even
more
because this [ __ ] wood nymph is
damaging around us so we're like let's
go back so we go back and then like talk
to some [ __ ] farm guy and he's like i
think it's there in broken spanish but
like
it's like no way how long he goes
sometime they don't have like even like
everything they gotta watch it's just
like you know the sun will go up there
and come down and then your day
so you just start walking these windy
things fog's rolling in it's getting
dark
and you just walk up windy windy windy
windy and just it just never stops you
just keep going up
and you're like all right we've got
probably an hour before it's like
the sun's gone you know we've got an
hour maybe or it's going away before
it's like completely dark and then we're
i don't i just like i don't know i don't
know how far it is
and then you finally [ __ ] you get to
the top
and then it's just like it flattens out
and you walk a few more steps and it's
just these giant crater lake remember um
have you ever gone to um
deep creek lake oh yeah yeah oh yeah i
mean it's that big but a circle so
imagine all d keep playing with all
those channels just put it together in
one giant circle it's just
gorgeous oh yeah
just gorgeous just ruining it for you
ruined
ruin i mean you had to try to have a
moment
we would do this game
oh my god just like it should have been
amazing
it should have been instantly you go up
there and everyone just gets quiet and
it's like
he's trying to write his [ __ ] book on
it in the moment this is moments like
these are when you're like dude save it
for your [ __ ] journal serious oh my
god he was trying to be like
really poetic and [ __ ] in the moment and
just like dude this is going go into the
tank
and just write about it later
have your [ __ ] feelings for a while
this is my problem with everyone on
their [ __ ] taking pictures of their
phones like you're commemorating the
moment you're not done doing it yet
you know yeah take a picture on your way
out of the music festival just with a
sign and like that'll bring back the
memories not every second
but oh man
so like uh
god damn there was this game we tried to
play we learned in the amazon it's
called a sound bath or nature bath i
forget what he said amazon ecuador is
the amazon the mountains and then the
beaches
so um
and then the island beaches but like
they uh so you walk like 20
20 yards ahead of the next guy 200 yards
ahead of this guy so you can't hear them
anymore and then you both you know he
walks
way ahead just walk very slowly
and just listen to this [ __ ] sound in
nature
right and just kind of let it wash over
you're not worried about talking to
anybody
so you guess it's just like really
chilly also you notice all the insect
noises and all the [ __ ] birds and
maybe some other birds far away you
notice that maybe a chainsaw way away
you just notice when you're not
you know concentrating what someone else
is saying
so i was like i noticed a bird it was
sunset and i noticed a bird that's when
they come out i was like let's play
i was like hey don't let's play the
[ __ ]
sound bath game
and this [ __ ] whoa what's that local
culture what is it or like you just be
quiet
and you let like the sound wash over
dude you just what you're saying you do
with your kids you know it's like
[ __ ] why you're getting quiet again
so you can be quiet the long time right
and then they're like i'm gonna win this
and you're like you [ __ ] idiots you
stupid idiots
here's why it's better on kids your kids
are not annoying at their core
i don't like to brag all the time
so we're able to do it for a little bit
we take tr
we take like moments too where it's like
we'd walk separately me and my partner
way up ahead way behind so it's like
sophie's choice bother one of us you
can't buy that it was it was almost like
a look like whoever he goes to the other
enjoy your freedom for a little bit
enjoy your nature you're quiet
have fun with bandit try to not to lose
track of us but like then
so we
go up 20 yards walk how many hours would
you say you spent with this person over
a full day oh okay so at this point
like 5 11.
also at night at the hiker so we're
having dinner we can't be like we're
having dinner alone today
he's with you yeah he's luggage oh yeah
it's three days of non-stop there's no
one else there's no one else with it god
forbid three whole days of just no one
else three of us the only english
speakers
i
and it doesn't start it's morning noon
and night
god
as you're doing the nature hike he he
starts making up the ground
and then starts talking
and it's like oh no no you gotta be
quiet you gotta be quiet
and he's okay
you walk ahead then he starts catching
up again
and you're like no no okay you go walk
ahead then
and he walks ahead then he'll stop like
hey dude so we gotta separate that's how
you get the nature thing
it was an hour of peace when he finally
got it but then that was it
an hour an hour and then it was like all
right sundown we had to walk the last
part of the way around the crate at
least we knew the crater was there so
the way around pitch black
um
god damn we had we had uh there was some
kids they were like hey which way is it
to go
and they were like um that way
tony's like hey here take a take a candy
i got a candidate it's like sweet
[ __ ] yeah
he's like hey you don't give kids the
local you don't canada locals
because it makes them incentivize them
to not go to school they'll just beg and
i'm like dude yeah we're not in like a
touristy area
you know what i mean they're not waiting
outside waiting for a [ __ ] hiker to
come by yeah all day for one piece of
candy it's not beggars in like bangkok
this is like different
because you shouldn't do it's like all
right don't do it fine like well and it
starts talking down to you about it i
was like
all right like the kid's fine he's
getting a piece of candy
my guy's like hey well and guess what in
scotland they say if a kid gives you the
direction you give them candy so that's
culture too
calm down we're starting to lose a
little bit so like uh
earlier past another kid which way is
the right way
she looks at her dad why is that wearing
my inner man wearing no shoes
yeah just looking at like hey which way
is
the you know the the light the crater
lake is just daddy why is he wearing our
shoes we're poor and we wear shoes we're
[ __ ]
mountain farmers and we wear shoes yeah
right why is this white
not wearing shoes in the [ __ ] cold
outdoors
so uh yeah i mean
it was it but whatever you make the best
of it i mean i got mocked later so we're
on the way home by who
my partner oh he was like you said you
said it'd be cool i'm like yeah i was
wrong
i mean i'll take some blame on that i
thought it'd be okay i don't know i just
thought it's another guy
i thought you know yeah all right
clearly i was wrong you're right i'm
sorry you're right
yeah that's like the worst case scenario
in any of these things just match up
with somebody you know that was the
worst guy because you couldn't get out
of it you couldn't be like actually you
know what i'm done in this town
i'm gonna go like we're just bailing it
on you [ __ ] you there was never a
thought to get up in the middle of the
night and just
break out
yeah for sure
we thought about it how can we but
they'll find me yeah
and if he sees this it's like dude
nothing personal just you're just
i was about the hair yeah just it just
wasn't a match it just wasn't a match
just like
you know everybody's got their favorites
and just like it just
all right all right
we'll stop it there
but uh before we do i told you before uh
we recorded advice you'd give to your 16
year old self
yeah you did so i'm curious what you
would say to your 16 year old self so
when i was 16 i was an orthodox jew
so
there'd probably be a few things i don't
know if what i'd understand because
that's got to go into what are you going
to understand as a 16 year old you can't
be like invest in bitcoin they're like
i'm not holding on to that information
what is that you know yeah
you can be like here's who's going to
win a championship game in two years you
know bet everything
i mean if i told him like hey girls want
to [ __ ] too don't be scared yeah as well
you know i that 16 year old boy be like
but i i mean no way i barely i've never
[ __ ] i'm not gonna [ __ ] for almost a
decade from now like there's no way i'm
even thinking in terms of that
it might be that though
chickens also want it
so you're not doing them a disservice by
like
asking a girl out
you know or hitting on somebody like if
you feel it [ __ ] go for it that's
perfect advice if you feel it go for it
yeah yeah be nice about it you want to
hang out sometime
but like
yeah i that took too long to when you
realized that you could just be like
yeah you're getting vibes from someone
he's like yeah let's get out of here you
can't you can't it's the way i waste
time
that or no i'd be that
i mean i could tell him like drop this
religion [ __ ] but he wouldn't do it not
then not that he would have done it when
his time
maybe that's i mean that's good advice
too though look at 27.
don't worry about it everybody's gonna
come around they'll be mad now but
they'll come around
you know at some point believe it or not
your dad is going to say you can get a
cheeseburger if you want out here
um promote whatever you want again
please
um
yoga with aria and friends is coming
in a month
right in secondly we're my friends
doing a month-long challenge in january
do yoga with me and my friends every day
for january if you want to until now get
ready there's a yoga with already
playlist on on youtube and my podcast
alright you should be skeptical tank is
out there right now i'll be in
boston on december 9th and denver coming
up in san francisco and
you know big cities coming next year ari
shafir.com
is where everything else but podcasts
are your favorite skeptics and because
on youtube and spotify and all those
things i love it dude thank you for
coming on for real it's great to have
you could you do that yeah i could do it
i can do that but i can't do it on my
left but i can get on my right that's
that old dip
oh yeah we're ready to do that dip [ __ ]
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryancichler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you